do you enjoy playing xbox 360 games on
your xbox one then you'll be happy to
hear that another awesome game from last
generation is on its way I'm Matt and
this is your backwards-compatible
GameSpot news updates
Far Cry 3 is the latest game to come to
the Xbox ones backwards compatibility
program Ubisoft's 2012 action-packed
shooter reinvented the Far Cry series
and received a score of 9 out of 10 in
game spots review it joins Far Cry 3
Blood Dragon which was added to the
backwards-compatible catalog last year
and if you already own Far Cry 3
digitally on Xbox 360 it should show up
automatically in your library however if
you own a physical copy all you have to
do is throw it in your console the Xbox
one backwards compatibility program has
more than 320 games with its most recent
editions being sultry Oh solitaire and
army of two we'll keep you updated as
more games are added but in the meantime
you can check out the full list on
gamespot comm if you're interested in
something a little more modern however
check out our video on everything we
know about destiny 2
[Music]